what's going on reject Nations Greg out
here
and I'm John guys the movie news world
the movies has released images of movies
that are yet to have trailers for them
people like doing videos on pictures I'm
gonna talk really quick first about the
x-men Dark Phoenix images right here
currently I'm wearing a Batman shirt
today because it's cool to be a youtuber
who goes against the grain or I just
didn't want to change my shirt to
satisfy stupid comments I am on the page
I believe 70 not 79 of x-men Dark
Phoenix right Here I am reading this
book hopefully I can finish this comic
book in time before this trailer comes
out not that I think it's gonna be
strongly similar to the graphic novel
maybe I'll earn some kudos points for
those people who are mad at me for not
wearing a Marvel shirt right now I think
I think this is what the video is gonna
be about Hey look there's a terrible
image of magneto right here oh man he's
in a collar and he's being dragged but
he looks well-dressed so he doesn't look
like he's been like an enslavement or
something I wonder what he's been up to
since since the events of them recapping
the dialogue an x-men apocalypse living
in someplace secluded looking some kind
of manual labor job again not you know
being a mutant looks like he's doing
something bad once more yeah I hope we
get more of Charles being like hey I
think there's some good in you I'm a
little sick right now guys is their
first video after Christmas I got sick
on Christmas I wonder if this is gonna
be a real significant part of the movie
now what looks interesting here though
there's an image of Jessica Chastain
who's being hailed as very pivotal
villainous role whose name has not yet
been revealed to the public of who she's
playing I'm really glad we're getting a
Dark Phoenix movie that is going to
be probably putting a lot of focus on
this Jessica Chastain character Jessica
Chastain I think she's a fantastic
actress she's an amazing amazing actress
I'm excited to see what role she plays
in here but if you're gonna get Jessica
Chastain it better be a badass role in
this image right here look at Charles
right there I'm assuming that's Charles
looks like this side of him yeah she's
clearly having power over the situation
because Charles looks scared and she
just looks like Jessica Chastain is in
every roof when do you ever see Jessica
Chastain play a weak character that
makes her look a little scary makes them
look more intimidating it's cool that
they're setting up a villain after
apocalypse who's not all crazy made-up
who's just about the performance that'll
make her an intimidating villain it
would be nice to have a one-two punch of
a good villain and a killer Jessica
Chastain perform that would be sick what
I've picked up from being 79 pages into
the Dark Phoenix comic book is that it's
not about Cyclops dying her romance with
Wolverine that we didn't really see
built in the other films and a lot of it
is Cyclops his personal relationship
with Jean as she's morphing more and
giving him more to the Dark Phoenix
which is a cool element and they have
this image here that kind of looks like
it's from this image of her here versus
being the seductress Jean Grey overall
Cyclops performance that we don't really
remember in the comic what they're
setting up here Xavier has kind of been
away for a while and Cyclops is kind of
the leader of the team and he has this
relationship with Jean and Jean has the
Dark Phoenix within her it effects their
relationship you know as she grows more
into it and it's a really intriguing
part of the comics so far I'm hoping
this movie takes the time to do that the
interesting thing about Dark Phoenix is
this could be our chance to give us a
Cyclops that we also have wanted for so
many years through that now it'll be a
nice thing for this to accomplish this
is what happens when you read source
material you can give better insight you
know video people flip out over images
like this I mean I feel like well we
really won't know what any of this means
so we see a trailer or possibly until we
even see the movie I'm hoping these are
good teases I feel like it's good teases
of what to come magneto usually has his
own solo thing going on because he's
freaking Michael Fassbender where's our
mystique image well it seems like these
might be teasing the three main plots of
it yeah you know which I get down with
that you know in ways I like when they
put out pictures just kind of like
here's a couple ideas that's why this
image of just of sophie Turner and
Cyclops is intriguing to me because I'm
hoping this will be the chance where we
get the Cyclops portrayal that we've
been wanting I hope they both get a
second chance to really make lasting
impression yeah those roles the images
aren't done oh man you know or images
we'll see what happens with our channel
is people are more interested in I was
talking about images doing trailer
reactions then when the movie review
comes out no one really watches those
the anticipation thoughts are apparently
more intriguing than the thoughts of the
actual material bumblebee oh yes Hayley
Seinfeld in the transformers you know
okay so of course you know when there's
a quote here to remind us what it's
about it takes place in the 80s of
course
and it's very character in storyline
driven which is a bit different but it
still has the elements at Transformers
fans loves and will see in the movie
this is her talking as a Hailee
Steinfeld talking about who I play a
character named Charlie Watson who is a
mechanic she's in high school incredibly
unique and strong and has something I
love about it as a lot of people tend to
underestimate her knowledge as she
continuously proves herself and what she
knows it creates this incredible
relationship with this transformer
sounds like a character in the
Transformers franchise I really hope
she's unique
I'm sure she's strong did you only see
the Mark Wahlberg ones even in the Mark
Wahlberg one there's a young girl Shia
LaBeouf is all a lot of is - this is a
unique thing they're talking about I
love this this looks like Herbie fully
loaded what a great image I feel like
it's just gonna be transformers but on
80s nostalgia it sounds like it's all
that's really gonna be different about
it I'm excited I guess to have a you
know strong knowledgeable female lead in
a Transformers movie but
doesn't exactly make me think that
they're gonna make a grin credible
transceivers movie this time around this
is the one they're gonna really develop
that character to make her incredibly
unique and also with bumblebee this
image I don't get how this can be an
exciting hit like who's gonna a who's
gonna see this and know this is
transformers B who is a fan of
transformers who's gonna truly get
jacked up by this I don't know I don't
really know the cartoons and all that I
don't know this is an actual bumblebee
thing for you hardcore Transformers fans
maybe your navy at it but as a person
who only watches the movies this image
does nothing yeah for me other than okay
I get it
it's the prequel yeah I mean it just
kind of reminds me that the movies is
there wait does John Cena in this - yeah
but dude Pamela Adlon interesting
whatever man you got John just hurling
like all of them I'm surprised I don't
know I would hope that maybe like a
spin-off could be something you know to
make this franchise kind of cool and fun
again I just don't have faith that that
will happen maybe it's good it's the
first one not from Michael Bay well yeah
and that's like I won't begrudge I like
the first Transformers find enough so I
won't begrudge them the idea that maybe
this one could be really fun I've seen a
few transformers now we'll see if it's a
studio problem or a Michael Bay problem
this will tell us that's why I think
this movie will ultimately tell us is
like oh if the zoo just got a different
director they would have made good
movies anyway guys
yeah these images Jack you up your mind
are you freaking like flipping balls are
you are you buying your tickets right
the jury's impatient thought on these
images I mean the x-men images are
cooler I like to talk more about images
when there's like you know Oh first look
at the new Hellboy like that's cool you
know
well then male like the look of
especially you know with comic-book
characters and stuff and they reveal
that first yeah they're gonna look like
like yeah that's fun to me that's
exciting this is like novel I think it's
like Oh neat I think this is saying our
trailer is coming
one feels like a trailer yeah x-men one
the best I can say about that is just
like oh it's kind of cool to have a
glimpse into those three plot lines yeah
if that's what that means it's not yeah
well you can subscribe it the real
rejects please click that notification
bell again notified every time one of
our videos is up haha we're youtubers we
give a lot of instructions on your end
make sure to follow us on social media
you can download and follow us first at
the Stardust app don't follow Tyrone
first don't follow the flick pic first
of all the schmoes first don't follow
Jeremy Jones first don't follow Wendy
Lee first of all Jabby go away first I
had to follow late to the party first
all the way to the party first follow us
first that's a new way of promoting
startup do that and become a patreon
object today it's a lot of fun over
there it's like a second YouTube channel
bye-bye